all right yuri so we have somebody that
uh shot me an email said he read my book
and i think you said that you disagreed
or that you wanted to challenge me on a
couple things oh well yes actually yeah
you see the thing is that uh i just came
across this red pill concept and your
book just i mean recently
yeah i'm almost 50 and i never
encountered any
problems which you described seriously
well i had my
okay i'm happily married with three
children i obviously
i had my share of drama in life i mean
obviously but nothing to write book
about seriously nothing okay
yeah so yeah so and uh i i'm a curious
person so uh
i think that your videos popped more
often than others on this subject
because we just live in the same area
more or less
right okay could be so and uh i bought
this book
uh i paid 150 canadian dollars for it
158 canadian dollars who did you buy it
from
just kidding i found it in my neighbor's
trash bin
oh you found it in your neighbor's trash
bin okay so we're going to start with
that
again i just bought it from my muslim
dude of course okay sorry
what do you want to challenge me on yuri
oh no no okay okay so uh
yeah before i do i would love to just uh
in three words describe what i
understood
because there's a good chance that i
didn't understand anything right
so in three words so what i understood
is that
first of all the man in our day and age
should wake up to the following facts
fact number one
the game is rigged against the man
meaning you go to family courts
or you look at any rules regarding the
law and so forth
and basically women are there to win
whatever you do they're right and you're
wrong so basically the game is right
fact number one
uh fact number two is that do you agree
with that are you disputing that
no no of course that's [ __ ]
so number two is that media
and all the culture i mean books tv
shows whatever you look at
are conditioning men to actually do
some strange and stupid things meaning
that the rational male
i mean rational man would say okay i
have a limited amount of
time money energy and i don't want waste
i don't want to waste all that
on people and women and i don't know
somebody else's children and so forth
right
so uh because in many cases there will
be no return on
investment so to speak right so that's
why
um the second fact men should wake up to
is that media and the whole thing is
conditioning you to do
basically and not really not really
rational things
so i think stupid you may even say
stupid right
okay and uh because of all that
it's basically boils down to the
following we
are 98 percent um
primates meaning we're 98 we are
primates right
yeah we're just more advanced form of
primate yeah exactly yeah so we're 98
similar to our i mean uh closest
ancestors i don't know apes
yeah so basically uh because of all
these two facts i mentioned before a man
should actually
learn the game meaning that they should
be aware of how all these instincts work
how they work in women how they work
with men
and based on that men should actually uh
act based on that right so i mean which
is uh which is in your book i mean
basic advice so yeah i should look okay
masculine you should be
a man on the mission i mean you should
make money that type of stuff right
got it yeah yeah is that correct is that
a fair assessment of what's all about
yeah so i'm not hearing what you
actually disagree with yet so what did
you want to challenge me
oh yeah okay so yeah yeah the last thing
is actually that uh
there are advices that the second one it
doesn't come from the red
red pill it just comes from your book i
believe is
it actually the other thing which man
should
consider is that
you should be very very careful which
people do you let into your life
yes meaning right either it's women or
men or friends or business partners
doesn't matter right
there's amount of red flags or other say
things which you should be very
considered okay
and this way again you will not waste
your money resources and so forth on
things which you shouldn't right okay so
you've done a good job summarizing it so
again what do you what are you
disagreeing with
so i wanted to make sure that i
understood everything properly right yes
yeah
okay otherwise challenge you would
wouldn't make any sense okay okay yeah
and if you don't mind can i ask you
just one more question which is not
related to the book
uh the question is this uh well
basically we all know
and it's a fact that statistics just
want to stop you for a second
i just want you to be mindful of time
because i usually give people like 10
minutes or so to kind of like come on
and ask questions
because there's a lot of people waiting
in the background area so i just want to
keep i know i know i don't trust me it
wouldn't be more than 10 minutes just
go ahead i'll be very sweet
so the thing is here's the question so
we all know
that um right now the marriages are on a
decline
in the western world we all know that
for whatever reason
uh so the question is do you think that
the state
would might in the future want to
fix that so i would say i will okay
from top of my head say um you want the
promotion okay
okay so so let me answer that question
because i mean you're asking me if i
think that the state is
going to change that or if we're going
to see an improvement and the answer to
that is no
i'm sorry not improvement but uh is it
possible that state will
interfere and make men marry more say
you want promotion you need to be
married man you know that type of well
they would have to offer incentives to
marriage which
don't really exist anymore like
traditionally in the past the incentive
to marriage would be
get married um you'd have your own
children you knew that they were yours
there was no question in your mind
you'd live you know forever and ever
until death do his part and risk your
importance sickness and health and all
sort of stuff and
you know she would compliment your life
you'd go to work bring home the bacon
she would cook it up and
that would be fine but the problem is is
that
when we had those um had that
family unit you know the the fabric of
all that working
men had all of the responsibility that
they have today but they also had
authority in their household
today men have no authority um as soon
as women say
you know what i'm bored or i'm done or
sally got divorced i think i want to get
divorced too and
um i'm just gonna you know let's let's
just go get divorce
there's no fault divorce that changes
things you know completely
um you could literally come home and
find your wife
in bed with two other men and your
children in the other room
and there's no consequences for that
whatsoever with family law
she would still be enriched if she used
the law to her benefits so
you'd have to see incentives given to
men to
want to get married and i don't see
incentives coming towards men
today there's not very many incentives
there's there's there's some tax
incentives if you
you know in canada you know for example
if you contribute to your spouse's rrsp
for example
if you're together forever then there'll
be benefit you know to that when you
both retire obviously
but they're i'm not seeing new
incentives being offered
you know towards forming yeah so meaning
that you don't see how the state can
make things
be even harsh on the man meaning that
force you into marriage or
actually actually this is probably the
best point here somebody just said in
the comments
things need to collapse i think there
needs to be a reset so that we can start
over again
when it comes to building family units
the way that we used to build them
okay all right okay okay so here is just
uh okay so now i'll just uh
make it quick seriously and i want to
challenge all these things
right so if if i can just speak a little
bit uninterrupted so and
then you can say whatever so number one
uh the point about game being rigged
against man right so that's number one
uh well believe it or not that my
question about how state
or state authorities can actually force
you into marriage or do
something to your relationship i wasn't
describing the distant pa
future i was actually describing the
past which actually happened
believe it or not no i no other than uh
reinhardt heidrik of all people was
fired was dishonorably discharged from
the navy
you know why because he proposed to a
woman
and then changed his mind and and it
it wasn't because his boss didn't like
him it's just was the policy
if you're an officer and you propose to
rule
that was it was number two my
great-grandfather
was it was in 1905 i guess
uh he was uh given a promotion so to
speak he said okay you
move to the new place with a promotion
so forth but there is a condition you
must be married
plus or other plus his superiors
had to choose not to choose but to
approve
his wife trust trust me
and uh more more than that if you are
about to marry you had to
put the deposit in form of money
to make sure that your family would be
okay
so my point is that this idea of
uh currently people being okay the game
being rigged
uh it comes from actually not knowing
the perspective of where we are in
history
we are trust me okay life is not perfect
i agree but if you compare to how our
grandfathers lived
we are in a very very favorable position
what people what what okay so okay so
you disagree with the assessment
yeah what modern people tend to do is
they tend to
confuse the their but their
lack of responsibility for their they
confuse it with oppression
i have chosen the wrong woman and and
this has consequences
i have chosen the wrong cryptocurrency
i'm losing my money
can i have it back no the system is
rigged for christ
okay well that's what it is so let me
just address that
because we'll we'll just deal with the
one point so we don't have
the other two to make sure that we at
least cover one thing for you so you can
get some satisfaction here
um marriage today is a contract that you
sign with somebody else
a woman obviously where she is rewarded
for breaking that
contract at no time in history did that
exist there's a book by stephanie koontz
called marriage of history which i'd
recommend that you read since you're
very interested in marriage and
in the past of marriage but marriage in
the past had nothing to do with
uh love children or any of those things
it was about the acquisition of in-laws
and
you know uh creating that unity so that
you could deal with problems as they
came up right if there was
if there was a medical issue you
probably had a doctor in the family but
it was
better off right now right no we'll hear
me out for a sec so i can finish because
at no time in history were women ever
rewarded for breaking that contract
in the past if she wanted to get
divorced and leave him
he would often be left with the children
and any assets that were
in the matrimonial home or even brought
to the marriage so if she was bringing
land you know for example
he would often keep that so he would
keep the kids and the land
she would go back to her family
sometimes she would go work on a brothel
and this is all factual stuff they
pulled from court records from
uh diaries throughout history they went
back as far as they could collect all
the information so
the problem that i have with marriage
today which is what i'm warning men
about is
it's the it's a bad deal for men there's
an entire chapter on why smart men don't
marry and i broke that down in each
individual area
and i see that you disagree with it and
you're free to do so
yeah okay it's entirely it's entirely
for you my friend right
but that's that's the point so
if you want to learn more about marriage
read that book marriage
a history by stephanie coonson you get a
little bit more information on does that
help you
uh well yeah i mean i still okay i still
think that
obviously our generations are far better
off than
oh yeah i mean like you know we live
longer we live healthier
yeah even in terms of uh marriage
agreements you are free you're free to
go i mean private security
is no longer a problem for anybody for
men and women so
promiscuity was never a problem in the
past but today if a woman catches you
cheating she can divorce you
take your kids and half of your [ __ ]
whereas in the past the guy would
probably keep everything
so how has that improved today yeah i
mean you personally you personally can
be promiscuous all you want
it wasn't that easy what you're
suggesting yuri is that
you know you can be promiscuous today
without penalty
but you can't because if you're
promiscuous your wife catches you
cheating
again well you know hell hath no fury
like a woman scorn
if she wants to take half of your [ __ ]
and the children
she can and will do that and that's more
often than not the outcome
whereas a few hundred years ago you know
you could be promiscuous with impunity
and there would be no consequences
whatsoever there's there was no
no fault of divorce there was no
division of assets the kids often stayed
with the father
or the father's family so things have
changed you know dramatically
um to our mutual advantage to be honest
i mean
seriously listen you know
you can look outside you know right now
because we're in eastern standard time
and you could say it's dusk or it's dawn
you know depending on
which way you want to look at the sky i
just look at the facts and i compiled
them
and i put it together in a book and if
you don't like the book that's fine you
can leave a bad review let people know
what you think
give it to your neighbor whatever you
want but
i think that there's a lot of useful
information in there and if you want to
dive deeper on
you know the benefits of marriage today
versus the past
i'm telling you man read that book and
you're gonna get some more information
out of it
okay all right fine fair enough fair
enough okay now yeah
no no no no no no no no no no that's
been way more than 10 minutes my friend
you've been going on for close to 50 and
i got to get to the other guys one thing
one thing
i knew okay i knew that you're gonna cut
me off
i knew that well you're talking you're
talking really slow and really long and
i told you 10 minutes ago you've only
got 10 minutes and you've been going for
close to 15. okay so then just one thing
just google
i google this guy januz
korziak yes hold on a second let me just
let me just jot that down because i will
do that for you and
use that okay you don't need to do that
i mean okay i got it
you can do it later right polish
educator and why don't you want to
google this guy yeah yeah just in case
just in case
so uh about media which
actually conditions people to do that
too i mean to to become [ __ ] right to
become [ __ ]
yeah it's mother's day yeah there's some
application for media of course
but it's society has been around for a
long time yuri
yeah yeah exactly yeah well i will take
financial parental and emotional burden
of rising another man's children you are
by definition a taco right
okay that's from the book okay so google
that guy
okay so i google them yeah so is he
just just just interesting okay so i'll
look it up and i'll let you know
thanks yuri see you buddy
you